you know they say iron sharpens iron
right you know it's gonna you know it
doesn't kill you is only going to make
you stronger and it seems like I mean
you did all right man they you know they
tried to cancel you and take you off all
the platforms and I still see you
everywhere
to this day on every platform
yeah the cancellation certainly failed I
I would like to believe and I don't want
to sound arrogant but I think I'm one of
the first people if not the first that
it totally failed on because they came
at me completely they didn't come at me
with some half lazy cancellation they
deleted me from it was full Alex Jones
level deleted me from every single
application on on my phone froze my bank
accounts like completely tried to wreck
me financially lied about me in all the
mainstream news from CNN to Fox News to
all the British tabloids everywhere
lying about me they really went for me
completely and and it and it didn't work
so that's kind of uh interesting for
them to see their own weapon fail I just
don't know how they're gonna handle that
yeah it's like I mean who have we seen
canceled uh Alex Jones Milo yiannopoulos
um there's quite a few that I've seen
you know Trump you know there's quite a
few that I've seen the platform but you
somehow managed to
continue to put out content and messages
and get on I mean like the podcast that
you've been on have been off the chart I
mean I um to this day one of my favorite
ones is the um your mom's house podcast
and I told you this after you you
finished it I think you have a knack for
comedy and it's probably one of the
untapped uh you know tools that I think
you're probably gonna lean into a little
bit more because you're because you're
[ __ ] hilarious dude like you're a
funny guy thanks bro and I I do my best
uh yeah to use it when it needs to be
used to get the message across but yeah
it's interesting you say that because
they the people who have been canceled
at my level there's only four or five of
them I think I'm the fit and yeah I'm
the last one who's managed to stay all
over the social networks but the problem
is that comes with its own issues right
because when the Matrix cancels you you
have it goes in three stages first they
try and shut you up if that fails they
try and put you in jail for something
you didn't do and if that fails they
kill you right so slowly we're moving on
to stage two they've attempted already
uh to raise some [ __ ] like in the
height of the cancellation when they
were lying about me all over the news
they were calling up reporters whoever
these reporters are managed to find
details of my ex-girlfriends and were
calling up ex-girlfriends saying do you
have anything bad to say about Andrew
Tate we'll pay you a hundred thousand
pounds for a story which is effectively
a bride right you're effectively bribing
them 100 000 pounds to say bad things
about me trying to raise because their
their biggest problem with their
cancellation is that I'm somehow
dangerous to women but there's not a
single victim or a single woman who's
come forward in fact every woman has
come forward is saying the opposite
there's a bunch of hot girls coming
forward saying Tate's a nice guy so
they're like oh [ __ ] we need a victim
here so they were trying to buy victims
and that failed all my even my exes
stuck by me which actually surprised
even me because I think if you ask any
man if there to contact your last 20
exes would they stick by you for 100
grand and most of the diamonds no so
that failed and now and now they're
looking at new avenues This legal
letters starting to come through for a
bunch of garbage so now they're gonna
try and get me in trouble with the law
for things I haven't done because they
because because I failed to be it
happened in Canada you know this very
well they couldn't get the truckers to
go home so all of a sudden they're all
getting in legal trouble right all of a
sudden they're getting tax all to it and
this craziness and that craziness it's
what they do they weaponize the law
against you and they're gonna try that
one next
sort of legal strategies are they coming
at you with
so yeah they're gonna I've started
getting legal letters now for strange
things revisions of tax returns which is
fine I'm completely legit there uh
speeding [ __ ] driving license
infringements a car tax thing like
stupid tiny dumb [ __ ] is all starting to
come through at once someone has looked
at me or is looking at me in multiple
countries and just trying to find
anything they can nitpick at to send me
a letter for to get me in trouble for
and it's it's a message it's a warning
it's a warning that everyone is guilty
if we want them to be guilty we've told
you to be quiet you're not being quiet
so you're gonna have to pay the price
and I think that's their next attempt on
me it's going to be a legal attempt
but the problem is all of this is a PR
War this is what most people don't
understand about the world it's all a PR
spin even if you look at America America
start all the world's Wars right but
it's not because they're so good at
Waging War obviously that's part of it
they don't start to lose but it's also
because they're very good at controlling
the narrative and psyoping people into
believing these wars are necessary and
that's what they do when they canceled
me they really tried hard to convince
the population that I'm dangerous and I
deserve it and that failed but even if
they were to get me in some kind of
legal trouble they're going to try again
with the media machine Andrew Tate
well-known misogynist thief whatever
they're gonna say and they're going to
try and convince the world of it and I
think that the problem they're starting
to come up against is that people don't
believe them when it comes to me because
everyone knows that what they did to me
was unfair and as soon as they say my
name they just think they're lying about
him that's [ __ ] and that's the
problem they're facing one of the things
I find hilarious is is the narrative
that you're a misogynist right because
you'll see these Street interviews
you've probably seen them as well where
guys will take your contents and like
read a line and be like okay well this
person said this so what do you think of
it and then the girls would be like oh
yeah I really like that kind of guy so
and then they'll say well that's Andrew
Tate so what do you think oh no he's a
misogynist and then he'll continue on
and say well can you define a misogynist
and they can't they're just like no I
don't like him because because the
narrative because the mainstream media
you know because you know the Matrix
told me not to like him sort of thing so
it's it's funny how people just sort of
conform to what they're told to sort of
like lean into like undertake that man
man with Cobra wrapped around Nazar bad
man right you know what and and what's
and what's crazy about it is this what's
crazy is these people who dislike me
have a emotional response it's not even
a logical response if you ask him about
me they go no I hate him hate is an
emotion right they feel something and
what actually is quite interesting to me
is that the Matrix itself is convincing
people to have feelings to have emotions
for reasons they do not themselves
understand they can't explain what
misogynist is they can't say anything
I've said they don't know why they're
supposed to dislike me but they still
have a strong emotional response and
this Jesus goes to show the power of the
programming if the Matrix can convince
you to feel hate which is a very
visceral very strong emotion for
somebody and you don't even know why
that shows how completely and utterly
programmed you are and most people are
walking through the world programmable
to this degree and this is how you have
the world's worst things the worst
things in history that have ever
happened happening because people are
convinced to hate somebody or something
or some group they don't even truly know
why there's no logical reasoning but the
programming's been installed and these
people are slaves they're slave minded
because if they fought for themselves
they'd realize they have no reason to
dislike me and and the whole
misogynistic [ __ ] because it is
[ __ ] is it was only it wasn't
because of anything I said it was purely
because of the influence I had because I
was large and because I was a masculine
man who said don't take [ __ ] they were
just looking for an attack angle and it
was a weaponized virtue I think they
were trying to look for a reason to get
rid of me but it's completely clown
world it's insane
yeah
um so anti-fragility you're familiar
with the concept
yep
so you're very anti-fragile
um in an environment like this I know
that you set yourself up to sort of be
that way before the [ __ ] sort of Hit the
proverbial fan where you have multiple
passports multiple driver's license your
you know Diversified you don't hold much
in your name as far as real estate and
stuff like that did that did that play a
significant role when they came at you
to to take you down to deep platform you
like how like how robust was that system
for you because it seems like it was
pretty good yeah like absolutely and
completely yeah yeah absolutely and
completely so my system obviously we're
live on the internet so I'll be careful
what I say but my system has been
Flawless and that's because it's
designed to be and I've always
understood to a degree that the Matrix
is going to come for me and attack me
and I'm very thankful I was as paranoid
as I was because there's times where I
put in a whole bunch of money a bunch of
time a bunch of effort into organizing
certain things and people didn't truly
understand why I did it but anything
that was remaining in my name in a
western country was destroyed so I had
any bank account in my name was frozen
millions of dollars were seized if I had
any property in my name I'm sure it
would be trouble all around it
um any companies that were in my name
were are under investigation so
everything that is remaining all the
things are remaining are things I
protected specifically and you protect
things very simply I'll make it very
clear to the internet how you protect
yourself against the Matrix you do it in
in a few simple steps the the first step
is to make sure you have as little as
possible in your personal name that's
the first thing they can be owned by
entities or companies or people you
trust completely which of course is rare
or trusts that's the first way the
second way you do it is you try and
spread it across multiple jurisdictions
because even the police they are still
human and there's still law that they
must follow even though I think they're
criminals and they break as many laws as
they can they can break the laws of
their own country relatively easily the
police but they can't break the laws of
foreign Nations very easily so let's say
you had a LLC or a company in Canada
let's say Canada instead of owning that
Canadian company you should get a
company in Singapore to own that
Canadian company and then that company
in Singapore should be owned by a trust
in the Cook Islands which is then owned
by an entity in Vanuatu off the coast of
Australia so now for them to get to the
bottom of it they have to talk to five
or six different governments some of
which are very small and act lazy slow
to reply backlogged and it makes it
extremely difficult for them to get the
bottom of anything and this is why the
rich do what they do this is why they
deal with all these weird South American
countries and Panama papers and all this
kind of stuff because by adding all
those layers of jurisdiction it becomes
nearly impossible for one entity to
penetrate and the third thing you can do
to make yourself anti-fragile which I've
done is you need to penetrate the
non-english speaking world so in my
example if I were to go to any kind of
payment processor for example they'd
type my name in and Google me or Google
anything to do with me and say no he's
bad news moves there's bad English
speaking press about him no but if I
were to get a payment processor that is
primarily Chinese based out of Singapore
they don't care why would they care that
I'm not in their sphere they don't give
a [ __ ] so or an Arab based let's say
here in the Arab world so you have to
also escape the English-speaking world
and find ways to get your things done in
different jurisdictions as such and that
makes you anti-fragile and that
anti-fragilities worked perfectly for me
like they've yet to actually damage me
they think they have but they've yet to
actually damage me I'll tell you a very
funny story and in the height of the
cancellation they they decided to do a
daily mail piece on me a huge hit piece
and the hit piece was that they looked
up my name and they could see that I had
a few outpaid not paid parking bills and
stuff I had like a thousand dollars of
unpaid debts of parking bills and it was
registered to my mother's old address
where she used to live which is
obviously in a very poor area and uh I I
had no credit cards nothing so they did
this whole report on me and they said
the whole expose I'm not really a
Millionaire right and it was he owes
money and he he's registered to this
terrible address and uh we can't find
any assets in his name he's a Brokey and
they contacted my PR Company before they
released it for a statement and and my
statement was absolutely amazing
detective work I'm sure you understand
that all rich people complete hold
everything completely in their names the
Bugatti I'm driving is fake and the
private jets I am are I'm on are fake
please print this story and when I
replied that they didn't even print the
story because I think they realized that
everyone's gonna laugh at them but they
tried very hard to find out what I own
and where it is ETC and the only way you
can protect it is to hide it you
shouldn't have to do these things right
but you do this is what people don't
understand people call me paranoid you
if you're just gonna buy a house and
keep it in your name and say I own this
house you're going to learn very quickly
you don't own a [ __ ] thing when you
order the government you have to hide
behind layers it's unfortunate but it's
the game hey guys I really hope that you
enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational Essentials
for health immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out